la préparation est plus longue pour un
rétablissement plus rapide dans cette
clinique de versailles à la pointe de la
technologie sur la chirurgie vertébrale
la chirurgie et mini invasive
le but est d'être le moins agressif
possible de faire saigner le moins
possible d'ouvrir le moins possible aux
prendre le moindre est ce possible pour
cela le bloc opératoire un équipement
spécial encore peu répandu de par son
coût on a des moyens d'imagerie avec des
systèmes de guidage système de
reconstruction que dimensionnelle qui
vont aider le chirurgien à voir aussi
bien que s'il avait ouvert complètement
a guidé son geste
et à rendre le geste encore une fois
moins lourd pour le patient en fait
cette machine appelée aux armes ce qui
est une première fois le patient pour
prendre toutes les mesures nécessaires
aux chirurgiens et les images 3d une
fois qu'elles vont être acquise
elles vont être injectés dans la
navigation pour virtualiser en 3d comme
vraiment celle ses principes grossier on
va dire du gps qui repère une voiture
sur la route va nous on va repérer les
instruments chirurgicaux sur la colonne
en fait ces instruments il peut
désormais les retrouver sur son écran
qui va l'aider à opérer de façon très
précise pour ce patient atteint de
scoliose le docteur le peintre va
retirer trois disques de la colonne
vertébrale et les remplacer par des
implants après plusieurs mesures de
précisions le chirurgien peut introduire
une broche puis son système d'écartement
pour aller chercher le disque a retiré
le tout sous couvert d'un euro
monitoring pour s'assurer que
l'opération n'est pas agressif pour les
racines nerveuses tout doucement
une fois le disque totalement retiré le
chirurgien peut placer l'implant et
n'hésitent pas à s'y prendre à plusieurs
fois en contrôlant chaque geste par le
scanner rien on a des repères radiopaq
sur l'implant qu'on m'ait et en les
aligne à des structures anatomiques bien
précises pour que le plan soit
positionné comme on le désire là il est
positionné comme on le désire voilà plus
que deux disques a remplacé pour que le
patient ressortent sans ses douleurs de
dos au total l'opération dure environ
une heure et demie face